[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala nos acompaña como todas
las mañanas en nuestro estudio mar buena
mañana de jueves hoy vamos a empezar
nuestra Crónica en Venezuela los
impactos de la deforestación y también
el cambio climático en la malaria mar si
Raúl muy buenos días Vamos a recuperar
unos datos de un estudio Pero antes y no
sé si lo sabían pero o sea Venezuela
tenía una gran historia de éxito contra
la malaria en los años 40 era un país
que como gran parte de América Latina
estaba muy golpeada por esta enfermedad
pero en unos 20 años hasta los años 60
hubo una campaña de erradicación muy
grande que hizo que Venezuela eliminara
en más de dos tercios de su país es la
presencia de esta enfermedad y llegaron
a principios de los años 60 estar a cero
muertes por cada 10.000 habitantes una
tasa bajísima no algo que lo estuvo a
punto de Eliminar esta enfermedad o al
menos de controlarla pero esta
enfermedad ha vuelto a aumentar
progresivamente a partir de esos
momentos y parece que Venezuela haya en
cambio retrocedido en el tiempo entre el
2000 y 2019 los casos aumentaron un
1.200 por ciento no y hay varias
explicaciones por un lado por supuesto
la crisis social política la falta de
acceso medicamentos también que se
cesaron muchos de los programas de
control de esta enfermedad pero
precisamente este estudio que
mencionábamos al principio publicado en
delanted pone de relevancia otro motivo
y es la deforestación y la minería
ilegal no lo que le llaman degradación
del clima según los datos que ha
recogido este estudio esta degradación
del clima es responsable de que haya
aumentado el plasmodium falsiparum que
es uno de los dos bacterias Perdón
parásitos que provocan la malaria en un
27% y del vivax 23% el vivax es el que
es más prevalente en América Latina y
también en Venezuela el otro En cambio
es más prevalente en África pero bueno
tenemos estos datos que nos permiten
concluir que aproximadamente un cuarto
de estos nuevos casos de malar y de este
crecimiento de los casos se es
responsable de esta minería ilegal de
esta deforestación y de estas acciones
humanas en contra del clima mar
cambiamos ahora información nos vamos
hasta Haití para hablar del brote de
cólera que atraviesa esa nación cada día
más preocupante sí Raúl ayer por la
noche llegaron cifras algo preocupantes
de unicef pero vamos a dejar que Juan
Pablo lucumí en su informe nos lo
explique
el cólera está enfermando a los niños de
Haití el 40% de los casos por el brote
son de menores de edad pero expertos del
fondo de Naciones Unidas para la
infancia temen que esta cifra sea mayor
Ya que en el empobrecido país de más de
11 millones de habitantes escasean los
informes en el área de salud la cuestión
es que la desnutrición y el cólera se
retroalimentan Así que si estás
desnutrido serás más débil por lo que es
más probable que contraigas cólera y
mueras lo que también pasa es que a
veces los niños tienen cólera o diarrea
y luego se deshidratan y llegan a la
desnutrición entonces uno puede conducir
al otro y viceversa ambos son terribles
para los niños y es algo que realmente
puede matarlos y al panorama de salud se
le suma la profunda crisis política y de
seguridad de Haití con altos de
registros de desnutrición y poco acceso
a productos básicos en Haití se puede
romper el círculo vicioso entre la
desnutrición y el cólera un tratamiento
sencillo asequible y eficaz puede salvar
la vida de los niños siempre que
lleguemos a las familias más vulnerables
antes de que sea demasiado verde pero
las áreas urbanas pobres más afectadas
por el brote de cólera también están
bajo el control de bandas fuertemente
armadas en medio de la violencia armada
generalizada y la inseguridad en gran
parte de la capital los equipos
humanitarios caminan sobre cáscaras de
huevo entre las acciones conjuntas que
ha desplegado unicef se encuentran 245
kits de cólera con vitaminas y
antibióticos
135.000 pastillas potabilizadoras de
agua
468,160 litros de agua distribuidos en
camiones cisterna 300.000 sobres de
alimentos terapéuticos anuncios de
prevención del cólera por radio
televisión y folletos sin embargo el
organismo de la ONU asegura que todavía
necesita
27,5 millones de dólares para asistir a
más de 1,4 millones de personas
mar y también hay novedades alrededor de
las vacunas contra esta enfermedad
contra el cólera si Raúl es una buena
noticia Aunque quizás tardará todavía
unos años sin materializarse Y es que
hay un nuevo acuerdo entre bioback del
instituto de vacunas de Sudáfrica y
también la ong internacional
que tienen un acuerdo ahora de
transferencia de tecnología para que
desde Sudáfrica se puedan empezar a
producir las vacunas orales contra el
cólera hasta ahora solo hacían el
proceso de terminar no como decíamos
hemos explicado varias veces con el
covid 19 y precisamente con este caso
del cólera se ha hecho lo que se estaba
pidiendo alrededor de las vacunas contra
la pandemia de coronavirus que es hacer
esta transferencia de energía para qué
países de otros lugares del mundo por
ejemplo países con menos recursos puedan
empezar a producir sus propias vacunas y
que sean más accesibles para todo el
mundo es importante también porque
recordemos que además de Haití hay en
total 29 países que ahora mismo están
sufriendo un brote de cólera por ejemplo
las imágenes de aquí son de malawi y hay
una escasez de vacunas que ha hecho que
la Organización Mundial de la salud solo
recomiende una dosis en vez de dos y
finalizamos con una cifra que nos
debería poner en alerta sí simplemente
terminamos con esto publicada por el
bien journal y es que en todo el mundo
son mil millones de jóvenes los que
están estamos también en riesgo de
perder audición por culpa de usar los
audífonos o por tener malos hábitos de
audición no sé si también te cuentas
entre ellos 100% tomar Pues bueno pues
toca bajar cartas en el asunto Bajar el
volumen y bueno cuidar nuestra salud que
es lo único que tenemos que podemos
controlar nosotros por supuesto en
muchas ocasiones Gracias como siempre
para mañana con más mañana